བསྟན་འཛིན་བདེ་སྐྱིད་མ་རེད་(ད)།བསྟན་འཛིན་པད་སྐྱིད་རེད།
ལབ་མེད། བསྟན་འཛིན་པད་སྐྱིད་ལབ་ཡིན།
ང་ལ་སྐར་མ་རག་སོང་འདི། ནམ་མཁའི་ཟླ་བ་ཕྱེད་ཀ
གློག་༼སྤར་༽རེད།
འབུ་ལ། འབུ་ལ་གློག་༼སྤར་༽༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
འབུ་ལ་གློག་༼སྤར་༽གི་ཡོད།
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་གར། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་གར་ལབ་མེད་བས།
ཏིག་ཙ་སྒུགས་ད།
ད་ལྟ། ས་ལ་མཐོང་གི་འདུག
ཏིག་ཙ་བལྟ་ག
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽གཅིག་གྱིས་(ད)།
སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ། ༼སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་༽
སྔོན་མ་སྔོན་མ་ཁྱི་འགྲོ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
ཁྱི་དེས་མི་ལ་ས་རྒྱག་གར་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ཁྱི་དེ་ནང་ལ་གཉིད་བྱས་མར་ཉལ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ཁྱི་དེ་(ར་)
སྤྲུལ་གཅིག་བསླེབས་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ཁྱི་དེ་མཉམ་དུ་སྦྲུང་གཅིག་
སྦྲུལ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། གཉིད་ཁུག་གི་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་བྲོས་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
སྦྲུལ་དེ་མར་ཟག་(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ Baby དེ་མར་ཉལ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
ནང་ལ་ཨ་མ་མཉམ་དུ་བསྡད་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽རྫོགས་རེད།
ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས། ངས་བཤད་ཐུབ་ཀྱི་མེད།
༼སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་༽(ར་)པུ་གུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་གཅིག་Baby ནང་ལ་བསྡད་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ཁོང་ཚོ་གཉིས་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོང་ཚོ་གཉིས་སྐྱིད་པོ་བཏང་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
ཁོང་ཚོ་གཉིས་དེ་(ར་)ནང་ལ་བསྡད་བསྡད་ནས་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་བྱས་ནས་(ར)། TV ལྟ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ཁོང་ཚོ་༼ར་༽མཉམ་དུ་སོ་རྒྱག་ག་ཡོང་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽baby ཟ་༼འགྲོའོ་༽བྱས་རེད་(ད)།དེ་ནས་baby ཟ་རེད།
ངའི་baby ཟ་མ་རེད།
ངའི་ནང་ལ། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་གི་ཡོད་རེད།
༼ཁབ་ཟས་༽ཟ་༼ཡ་༽དགའ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད། ང་གཉིས་གཉིས་ཆ།
ཅོ་ཅོ་དང་ང་ཚོ་ཁ་ཟས།
བཏུང་༼ཡ་༽རེད་བས།
ཅི་གང་དགའ་པོ་མེད། ༼ཁབ་ཟས་༽གཅིག་པོ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད།
ཇག་མ་དང་ཕྱུ་པ།
ཁྱི་རྩེད་མོ། ཁྱི་རྫུན་མ་རྫུན་མ་རྩེད།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱས་ནས་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད་ཁྱི།
དེ་ཟ་ག་ཡོང་གི་རེད་ཨ་ཅག་གི་དེ།། ཁྱི་དེ། མིག་ཤེལ་ཟ་ག་ཡོང་གི་ཡོད་རེད་ཁྱི།
ཁ་ནང་ལ་བླུགས་སོང་།
ཁྱི་རེད། འ་འུང་འ་འུང་། ཡོང་གི་འདུག་ད་ཡོང་གི་འདུག སོ་བརྒྱབ་སོང་།
ངུ་མི་ཡོང་།
ཕྱེ་ད།
དེ་ག་རེ་རེད།
ག་རེ་རེད་༼ཞག༽
ཉྭ་སྟོན་དགོས་ཉྭ།
འདི་ཉྭ་བརྒྱབ་ལ།
baby རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ། baby རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ།་རྒྱབ་ལ། baby རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ།ball མང་པོ།
འདི་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽མིན།
འདི་སུ་རེད་༼ཞག༽ སུ་རེད།
ཨ་ཅག འགྲོ་སོང་(ད)།
གཞན་པ་གཅིག གཞན་པ་སྟོན་ད།
ཨ་ཅག་འདི་སྦུག་ལ་པར་མང་པོ་འོ་ཡོ་འདུག་ག
ཡང་བླུགས། འདི།
[ཀར་ཊོན་]ལ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད།
ཨ་ཅག་སྟོན་ད་[ཀར་ཊོན་]ཁ་གྱི།
[ཀར་ཊོན་]སྦྲུལ་ཁ་གྱི། པུ་གུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)་སྦྲུལ་ཁ་གྱི།
ཨ་ཅག་སྟོན་ད་ལབ་སོང་ང་།
ལབ་༼ཡ་༽མིན།
ངས་ཆགས་བཅུག་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། ཆགས་བཅུག་ཡིན།
ཨ་ཅག་གཅིག་དགད་མོ་ཤོར་བསྡད་༼ཞག༽
ངས་འདི་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན་(ད)།
བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན་པས། ངས་སྟོན་ཡིན། སྟོན་ཐུབ་༼གི་༽ཡོད།
ཨ་ཅག་བཟོས་ད་ལབ་སོང་ང་།
མ་བྱེད་ལབ་སོང་ང་། སླེབས་༼གི་༽མི་འདུག་ག ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད།
འདི་ཚོ་ཚང་མ་Blank བཏང་དགོས་རེད། ཨ་ཅག་ཁ་གྱི།
ལྟད་མོ་ལྟ་༼ཡ་༽དགོས་རེད།
འདི་འདྲ་མི་འདྲ་འདུག་(ག་)ཨ་ཅག་འདི་ལ།
ཨ་ཅག་གཅིག་སྟོན་ད་ལབ་མ་སོང་ངས།
གཅིག་སྟོན་མིན།
Game རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན་(ད)། རྩེད་མོ་འདི་སྦུག་ལ་ཡོད་རེད།
ཕ་གིར་ནགས་ཁུངས་ནགས་ཁུངས་རེད་༼ཞག༽ འགྲོ་(ད)།
ཞེད་པ་ལ་ནགས་ཁུངས་རེད་༼ཞག༽
ནགས་ཁུངས་རེད་༼ཞག༽ ཨ་ཅག་ང་གཉིས་གཅིག་པོ་མ་ཤི་མི་འདུག་ག ཞེད་༼གི་༽རེད་གདོན་འདྲེ་སླེབས་༼གི་༽(ར)།
ཁ་ཚུམ། ཁ་ཚཱུམ་བྱས། འགྲོ། གདོན་འདྲེ་སླེབས་༼གི་༽མ་རེད་བས།
འདི་ང་ལ་cake གཉིས་རག་སོང་། Cake གཉིས་པ་ལགས་ང་གཉིས་ལ།
ད་སླེབས་༼གི་༽འདུག་སླེབས་༼གི་༽མི་འདུག་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། སླེབས་མ་༼ཞག༽
ཟླ་བ།
ཨ་ཅག་འདི་སྒང་དེ་Delet བཏང་༼ཡ་༽རེད། དེ་མ་རེད།
པ་ལགས་བལྟ་ག་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽ཡིན།
འདི། ང་འདི་བཟོས་ཚར་ཡིན།
སྒང་དེ་བཟོས་མེད།
པ་པ་གིས་ཨ་རི་ལ་ཡོད་ལབ་སོང་།
ངའི་པ་ལགས་གིས།
པ་ལགས་འདི།
ཨ་རི་ལ་ཡོད་ན་ཕལ་རྒྱུགས།
མ་བྱེད་(ད)།
པ་ལགས་དོན་གྲུབ་བསོད་ནམས།
ཨ་མ་དང་བདེ་ལེགས་ནང་ལ་ཡོད་རེད།
ཨ་མ་ད་ཁོང་ཚཽ་ནང་ལ་ཡོད་རེད།
ཅོ་ཅོ།
སླེབས་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽རེད་(བ)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽
ཅོ་ཅོ་ག་རེ་བྱེད་ཀྱི་ཡོད་འཛིན་གྲྭ་ནང་ལ།
ལབ་ཡིན། འགྲོ་༼གི་༽མི་འདུག
ཅོ་ཅོ་ཁྱེད་རང་གིས་ག་རེ་བྱེད་ཀྱི་ཡོད།
པ་ལགས་ང་ཚཽ་འདི་ལ་སླེབས་ཡོད།
པ་ལགས་ང་གཉིས་འདི་ལ་བསྡད་བསྡད་ཡོད།
ད་འགྲོ་སོང་།
པ་ལགས་རྩ་ལ་བཤད་ག་འགྲོ་ག
པ་ལགས་མཉམ་དུ།
ཅོ་ཅོ་
ཅོ་ཅོ། རང་འཛིན་གྲྭ་ནང་ལ་བསྡད་བསྡད་ཡོད། ཡི་གེ་ཀློག་བསྡད་ཡོད་པས་ཅོ་ཅོ།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽ཆགས་སོང་།
ང་པ་ལགས་ལས་ཀ་བྱེད་ས་ལ་ཡོད།
པ་ལགས་ལས་ཀ་ལ་ཡོད།
འགྲོ་མ་སོང་།
པ་ལགས་འགྲོ་སོང་ངས། འགྲོ་སོང་ལབ་སོང་།
འོག་མ་བདེ་ལེགས་ལ། ཨ་མ་དང་བདེ་ལེགས་ལ།
ཨ་མ་ལགས་བདེ་ལེགས་༼གིས་༽ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽འདུག་བདེ་ལེགས། ཨ་མ་ཁ་ལག་བཟོ་བསྡད་ཡོད་བས།
པ་ལགས་འགྲོ་རེད། འགྲོ་སོང་ངས། འགྲོ་སོང་ལབ་སོང་། སྐྱིད་པ་ལ།
གུས་འདུད། ཐུགས་ཆེ་གནང་།
པ་ལགས་ཨ་རི་ལ་ཡོད་མེད་པས། འདི་ཨ་རི་རེད་པས།
ག་རེ་བྱེད་ཀྱི་ཡོད་རེད། ཨ་རི་འདི་རེད་བས། ཨ་རི་གཞན་པ་གཅིག་ལ་བཏང་༼ཞག༽་དགོས།
ཡ་༼ཨ་ནས༽།
ཨ་རི་ཡ། ཡ་ཡ་་་་་་
ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱས་ན་ང་ལྟ་༼ཡ་༽མིན་ད།
ཡོང་གི་མི་འདུག ཡང་བསྐྱར་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽མིན།
ཙོག་གིར་མ་བསྡད་ན་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽ཆགས་༼གི་༽འདུག་ད་འདི། ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽ཆགས་ན་ཆགས་བཅུག་གི་མིན་ད།
ཏིག་ཙ་སྒུགས་ཨ།
ང་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ཨ་ཅག་བྱས་ཚར་སོང་ང་། ང་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(ད)།
ཨ་ཅག་མར་བཏང་ག ཨ་ཅག་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽མི་འདུག
Baby འདི། འོག་ལ་འཛུལ་༼གི་༽འདུག
རྫོགས་སོང་།
སྒྲུང་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་གཅིག་བཤད་ཡིན།
སྒྲུང་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་གཉིས།
རུལ་མེད། སྟོན་༼ཡ་༽མིན།
འདི་ཕྱེ་ད།
འདི་ང་སླེབས་སོང་།
འདི་ཚོ་སླེབས་༼གི་༽འདུག [ཀར་ཊོན་]།
འདི་གཅིག་པོ་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(བ)།
ངས་སྟོན་ཡིན་(ད)།
ངས་སྟོན་དགོས།
ངང་ལག ཏིག་ཙ་སྒུགས་ཨ།